- All right everybody let's wrap.
Yeah, I heard it.
Let's wrap up this hour
with one more story
sure to make you smile,
this is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
It takes a crazy amount of hard work
to land a full ride
scholarship for college.
So we should all be impressed
with 18 year old Josh in
St. Charles, Missouri,
who secured a four year scholarship
worth $43,000, that's incredible.
(audience cheering)
Way to go.
But, that's only part of
what makes him remarkable.
Now that he set on his educational path.
He wants to pay it
forward to other students.
Incredible.
So he's using the money
he saved up for college
to give out scholarships of his own.
I love him.
His name is Josh.
We have Josh on the line.
Say hi y'all.
(audience cheering)
Hi Josh.
- How you doing?
- Oh my gosh.
I want friends like you,
you're so sweet.
This is the sweetest thing ever
and first of all, congratulations
on your scholarship man.
That's so cool.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- So what are you studying?
- So I'm actually majoring
in biomedical sciences,
and I'm as SCMP in their
pre-optometry program
because my plan is to take my
degree in biomedical sciences
and become an optometrist,
because being an eye doctor is something
that's kind of interested
me for a long time,
'cause my family has very poor vision.
I wear contacts,
my mom wears contacts,
my brother wears contacts.
So I feel like it's just
a really important field of medicine.
That's going to be super
valuable in the future.
(audience cheering)
- So now you're paying it forward,
so tell us about your scholarship.
- So yeah, so last year
during my senior year
in high school,
I decided to start a
scholarship fund called the
Joshua Nelson Leaders
In Action Scholarship.
Basically what encouraged me to start this
was my faith,
I'm a man of strong faith,
and I feel like it comes
from the biblical principle
of being of a cheerful giver,
'cause from a young age I've kinda
just been super excited to give back.
And once God opened a
door for me to be able
to give back in a big way,
then I jumped on it right away.
So, I decided to take a thousand dollars
out of my college savings,
and I decided to start
my own scholarship fund.
And what happened was a
local nonprofit organization
decided to pick up the story.
Local news station started picking it up
and we got a lot of traction,
and we were able to raise
$17,000 in scholarships
to where the Joshua Nelson
Leaders in Action Scholarship
would be funded for over a decade.
- That's incredible,
you are such a remarkable young man.
Oh, the future is bright now.
Okay, well thank you so much, Josh.
I'm liking your posts right now, right.
- [Josh] Alright.
- Hey my man.
That's not all our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen at the Kelly Clarkson show
likes to celebrate incredible
people, just like you.
So they're gonna be using
their friction erasable pen
to write you a cheque
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Awesome.
- And I hear that it's your goal you know,
to create to where you can have $10,000
to be able to give someone,
so I'm gonna give you $9,000,
and you can make that 10.
(audience cheering)
And I'm all about educating people,
I think what you're doing,
is an amazing thing.
I think.
- [Josh] Thank you so much.
- People should not have to worry about
the financial part of it because,
you know education is.
- [Josh] Right.
- It brings so much opportunity to people.
So I think it's so
beautiful what you're doing.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.